hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 13 video all
about firestorm
the title of the episode was the nuclear
man so this was the introduction of what
firestorm is gonna look like in the DC
TV universe just like with barry allen's
flash shoot the producers have said that
there will be an evolution of the
firestorm costume so the costume that we
saw in this episode will change over
time they've taken their time
introducing the character but i think
once they establish and they'll start
using it more often what I'd really like
to see is firestorm become a critical
part of the finale I'll try to dig
through that a little bit as I work
through my top five moments in the
Easter eggs there's a whole bunch of
stuff going on in the episode so I'll
actually I'll explain some of the really
big stuff first okay just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet so let's get going
starting with blood samples Cisco said
that one was Barry's from the future so
we're talking like older Barry Allen
goes back in time and the other one was
unknown meaning it was not a match for
Wells a lot of you were asking questions
about this on Twitter while the episode
was going on so he said that he tested
both samples
meaning the e tested wells sample and it
was not a match meaning there are two
reverse flashes I don't really consider
that news I always felt like there were
gonna be two flashes there's gonna be a
crazy reverse flash and they'll be the
Harrison wells reverse flash that's
trying to save his wife here's what I
think the producers are doing with the
two villain characters the two reverse
flashes they're just mixing and matching
aspects of all the reverse flashes so
it'd be kind of misleading to call one
of them hunter zolomon and one of them
professor zoom because you'll have like
an a Abarth on character with aspects of
hunters elements characters so whenever
they finally reveal everything what bull
will say is like this is a oh Barth on
with hunter's elements backstory or this
is hunter zolomon with some aspects from
a Oh Bart Don's history so just remember
that when you're Theory crafting and yes
I think it was the crazy reverse flash
that killed Barry's mother as much as
Harrison wells seemed like a dick in
this episode like he wanted to kill
Ronnie Raymond and Professor Martin
Stein to stop the nuclear reaction he
shared his fries and he sacrificed the
Tachyon prototype he cannibalized that
to make the firestorm device technically
you could call him a villain because he
is the reverse-flash and he's deceiving
everyone he hurt a lot of people for
selfish reasons but that doesn't mean
that he's a psychotic serial killer and
it seems like the other reverse-flash
the one whose identity we don't know yet
it seems like he's more psycho
I think once they introduced time travel
on the show in the next couple of
episodes we'll start to learn who that
other reverse flashes and also if you
were confused by why they lingered on
the shot of that flash ring while
Pearson Wells was you know holding his
neck with the flash being like really
clear and frame I think what they're
teasing with that is that he just has a
much deeper connection to the flash a
lot of people when we first met him
thought he might be a future version of
Barry Allen especially with the flash
ring but the reverse flash also gets a
flash ring okay so moving into the fun
stuff top five moments number five
driving safely while kissing a pretty
girl probably one of the best Einstein
quotes I've ever heard a TV show throw
out Victor Garber was saying it talking
about his life but he shines the light
on what's going on in Barry's life it's
what inspires him to go after Ernie that
super hot pepper that's the show telling
us that they're gonna continue to be a
thing so I'm hoping Malisha out stays on
the show for a while because Linda Park
is a really big part of the flash
history of the comics and melis jobs
just a lot of fun it's just nice to have
a female on the show with her energy the
show would be so much less fun if no one
was having sex on it and actually I felt
like they really shined a light on that
in this episode too that there is a lot
of sex happening in Central City
especially if Barry's old house cougar
time for the win I'm gonna go ahead and
take a wild stab in the dark and say Jo
is not gonna tap that the funny thing is
is that the actor that plays Cisco said
that Cisco might be finding some romance
himself at a certain point wouldn't it
be funny if it like a post-credits scene
or in like the comic you see him quietly
go back to that house to go on a date
with that woman that would be so gross
than so funny at the same time but I
would like to see them bring on like
brie Larson from community I feel like
she would be a good date for Cisco on to
number four time travel
flash cinema wasn't it awesome how they
used the logic of the mirror to show
like a projector reel of the Flash's
fighting in the past we actually saw
them digging a little bit deeper into
that footage they ended up showing it to
Barry in the next episode so is the show
just pushing into the idea of time
travel they're gonna start exploring
time travel that'll cross through the
rest of the back of the season so as we
get further along in the episodes we'll
eventually see Barry start to
time-travel first it'll be kind of like
the groundhog stay situation where he
kind of stumbles through time travel he
accidentally stumbles into it I think by
the end of the season he'll actually
find a certain amount of control over
time traveling and now that Harrison
wells has destroyed his tachyon device
he can't time travel so if he's gonna go
back in time to save his wife he's gonna
have to find some other way
do it which actually leads into some
firestorm stuff so on to number three
firestorm versus the flash so this is
before they get him under control the
big action set piece between the flash
and firestorm this is a lot of fun it
was really an effect sequence and I feel
like the flash doesn't have a huge
budget but the effects always look great
they're usually ways to get around not
having a lot of money for effects one
you don't do them for an extended period
of time
and two you try to shoot them at night
so things don't stand out as much so you
don't focus as much on the details
that's also kind of how arrow gets
around their budget problems too they
both shoot 23 episodes of season but
they have a smaller budget than a lot of
major Network shows so they just they
don't have a lot of money to throw into
effects what I'm really interested to
see is what firestorms powers look like
now that he's slowly getting under
control moving on to number 2
firestorm joins team flash so he's not
officially on the team yet what what
happened at the end of the episode at
least what it seemed like happened is
that they were successful in separating
Ronnie Raymond from Martin Stein like
their device worked they have released
some descriptions for some of the future
episodes so they teased that obviously I
mean the firestorm character is still
gonna be a thing on the flash so if
they're gonna be firestorm they have to
merge into the matrix again so they're
probably gonna use that device to become
firestorm again I think mostly it's
gonna be like a control device help them
control their powers the real question
is is who's going to be controlling the
matrix who's gonna be the mind and
who'll be the body obviously it's a
really simple answer
I mean Robbie Amell is gonna be the
actor on the show so it's gonna be
Martin Stein driving the car in Ronnie
Ramon's body he'll be the car they
haven't said specifically whether or not
they're doing it but what I'm hoping to
see is we get a shot of like inside the
firestorm matrix with the floating heads
talking to each other
it'd be kind of like being inside Tony
Stark's helmet whatever he's talking to
Jarvis part of the energy between Ronnie
Raymond and Martin Stein in the comics
was the witty banter so I'm really
looking forward to that in my number 1
moment Altered Harrison wells plans in
general Eiling post-credits scene it's a
two-part episode so we've really seen
like half the story
general Eiling is gonna try and capture
firestorm and use him for military
purposes as a weapon pretty likely like
he was gonna try and do with plastique
earlier this season I also think that
answers Jason Russia's comment from the
previous episode the mystery backer that
they didn't know about the person who
provide the financial backing
it was probably general Eiling that's
why I think that when they found out
about the nuclear blast he was like
firestorm he didn't even need to think
about it he knew instantly what it was
so on the side of that because Harrison
wells clearly does not general Eiling
he'll probably try to help them out as
part of team flash but as the
reverse-flash as in terms of his secret
plans he sacrificed the Tachyon
prototype to create the quantum splicer
I'm wondering if whatever a new plan he
comes up with to time-travel involves
using fire storms energy I think we
should all remember too that the reverse
flash is weak against firestorm powers
both hot and cold stuff I mean that's
why the Rogues are also very important
because they have those weapons if team
flash is gonna fight the reverse flash I
feel like it would benefit them to use
firestorm and the Rogues if they're
gonna fight that villain they're gonna
have to use weapons that he's weak
against and those other characters are
the only ones that have those right now
it gets you even more pumped when
episode 18 is called all-star team up
even though that doesn't refer to
firestorm so let me know what was your
favorite mode from the episode and where
would you like to see them take the
firestorm character I mean do you want
to see Captain Atom in season 2 because
he's a big part of the firestorm comics
I think that would be awesome
like if they take their time introducing
firestorm then they can introduce
Captain Atom as part of that all in all
great episode so here are actually some
of the Easter eggs that I spotted that
that I haven't already mentioned yet so
one the Conway award that's actually
named after Jerry Conway he's the person
that created firestorm in the comics
Barry Allen says please don't flame on I
know that sounds like a fantastic for
reference but that's also a firestorm
reference that's something he says in
the comics whenever he fires his powers
up when they're talking about blood
samples on the screen here
they have both blue and yellow samples I
just visually I feel like this is an
Easter Egg for the reverse-flash the
yellow blood sample they also have a
nice heads-up display for the firestorm
matrix too on these computer monitors
while they're talking about it we see
Harrison wells flash ring here again
very prominently displayed
I can't wait for Barry Allen to get a
flash ring in the comics that has a
number of uses mostly the Wally West
flash used it to contain his suit so
when he was running around the suit
would come out of the ring I feel like
eventually we'll get there but it might
be a couple seasons away and finally the
adult blood sample from Barry Allen so
very clearly Barry Allen is time
traveling right now while the flash is
happening an older version of Barry
Allen is jumping around in the
timestream fighting the reverse-flash
trying to save his mother just like
Harrison well
in the future is probably trying to save
his wife just let's talk a little bit
more about that - Harrison wells yes I
do think he is someone from the future
he has knowledge of the future clearly
the thing about his wife dying though
that's truth regardless of where he is
from in the timeline like he came back
in time it got stuck I feel like his
wife died in a car crash or died in an
accident so he's telling the truth about
his wife he's just not telling the truth
about where he's from or his real
identity for those that are asking
gorilla grodd we'll be back in episode
15 at least I don't expect to see him in
next week's episode because general
Eiling is back we might get a Grodd
Easter egg at the end of the episode
hopefully we'll get an Easter Egg for
the new weather wizard too because he'll
be back in episode 15 or he'll debut in
episode 15 so losses have to look
forward to lots of time travel the other
reverse-flash finding out who he is
although I totally think it's Eddie
Thawne you guys can let me know if you
agree though the other reverse-flash
who is he I didn't really have any big
thumbs down about the episode I thought
they had it really interesting use of
music I mean uptown funk at the
beginning is kind of funny sometimes the
songs that they pick are a little bit
weird and it takes you out of it
something else I also I noticed I feel
like melis jao is kind of like a
Felicity type character notice what
she's wearing
she always seems like she's dressed to
catch her eye just like everyone else in
the background is dressed in really
plain colors but she's wearing this
crazy-looking pattern I tried to find an
Easter egg in her dress but I didn't see
anything that jumped out at me
so if you think her dress like that
pattern is an easter egg for some comic
book thing let me know in related news I
know a lot of you are asking about my
Gotham video I just because of the
special video the fun video I posted
yesterday I had to move it around I am
posting Gotham next I'll get that out
before arrow tonight I don't know if
I'll get my agent Carter video out
before that though if I don't I'll just
post it after air on Thursday so don't
worry I'm also doing Q nays for the
flash and arrow this week and for the
big Marvel Sony announcement so there's
still plenty of time to ask questions to
think of stuff for that okay so while
you guys wait for all that to happen you
can click here to catch up on the flash
and you can click here for my explainer
for the Spider Man Marvel announcement
spider-man in the MCU everyone is still
freaking out I'm still freaking out a
little bit about it so thank you so much
for watching everybody high five I'll
see you tomorrow
you